major story that broke late last week
about former interim DNC chairperson
Donna Brazile and what she characterizes
as allegations that yes Hillary Clinton
stole the Democratic primary from Bernie
Sanders I did an hour livestream about
this late last week it's archived on our
youtube channel youtube.com slash the
david pakman show check it out two
questions on it etc and I want to start
first of all by pointing out that
everybody who is emailing me over the
weekend saying David you're never going
to talk about this story because you're
a shill for Hillary or a shill for the
Democrats or whatever I would ask what
evidence suggests that number one and
number two just remind you that we don't
do shows over the weekend so I've been
studying this story all weekend and of
course I'm going to talk about it today
and the headlines were donna brazile
came clean about a coordinated effort
between Hillary Clinton and DNC staffers
the DNC to steal the primary election
and intuitively we knew that Hillary
Clinton and the DNC were working
together right we talked about debate
scheduling we talked about sharing
offices we talked about some of what we
knew about fundraising and the way
fundraising was being done the DNC was
in no way an unbiased arbiter in the
Democratic primary now Brazil's
allegations specifically are that the
Democratic National Committee organized
a sort of money-laundering scheme with
Hillary Clinton by which people would
donate money to the DNC and that then
Hillary Clinton would get the majority
of that money herself and this is a way
to circumvent these individual
contribution limits you can donate to
each state Democratic Party and then to
the National Democratic Party and that
is going to be way more money than you
would be allowed to donate by federal
election law just to Hillary Clinton
directly so these are bombshell
allegations and Donna Brazile wrote an
article in Politico she totally throws
debbie Wasserman Schultz the DNC chair
that was replaced by Donna Brazile under
the bus and doesn't take any blame now
is donna brazil's account completely
accurate can we think of some reasons
why we should look with just as
skeptical and i at what donna Brazile
has said
as we looked at what Hillary Clinton has
said Debbie wasserman-schultz and I
think that we should we should take all
claims with a skeptical eye donna
Brazile says had she known about this
she never would have agreed to become
interim chair of the DNC maybe who knows
really easy to say that now Donna
Brazile has also made it clear that she
wants to sell books by the timing of
this she could have quote come clean
about this before now she has a book
that she wants to sell and the
revelations are certainly well timed
with that so this is a big deal there
are people on the Left who were
splitting themselves into Brazil is
literally true in every word and it
confirms everything we suspected or
Brazil can't be trusted at all now this
is a big deal the money supposedly for
the eventual candidate was in advance
allegedly taken out of the DNC mostly by
the Clinton campaign nothing short of
monumental it's essentially a legal type
of money laundering money laundering is
a crime but this is money laundering
used colloquially what we mean is it was
a way to get Hillary Clinton money that
was actually donated to the DNC but
there's no indication that this would be
illegal now the counter to this is what
we've seen the counter arguments come
out over the weekend one counter is well
hey Bernie had a very similar joint
fundraising agreement in place but he
never used it he opted not to activate
it there's truth to that
and there's distortion to that the
reality is that both Hillary Clinton and
Bernie Sanders had joint fundraising
agreements with the DNC it's true that
Bernie Sanders never activated his but
there is also a separate agreement here
which gave Hillary Clinton's campaign
oversight over staffing and policy and
Bernie Sanders did not have an agreement
that included that so don't fall for
that talking point a whole cloth but
there is some truth to that and there
are groups now fighting over the
minutiae of this and I think that that's
actually a distortion I think that the
right conversation is the big picture no
matter how you slice it here is that
Democrats Inc chose Hillary right the
degree to which the process was
corrupted we could debate but I think
that's actually a waste of time
whatever Donna Brazile says did it
happened exactly like she says or was it
slightly different than she says that is
less relevant now the DNC is failing
Bigley here and there is no
straightening that out for now the DNC
the Democratic Party needs to move to
the left there's no indication they're
ready to do it they need to really purge
the organization and do a total reset
Tom Perez as the DNC chair and there's
no indication that he's going to be
doing that either
am i stunned by the details of Donna
Brazil's revelations not really it's
more or less the exact type of thing
that anyone who paid attention to the
public facing campaigns all along would
have assumed was happening do I believe
Donna Brazil's version of her
involvement she said oh you know I
thought about starting a process to
replace Hillary with Joe Biden which was
a whole other story and I never would
have taken the job I don't know is she
being candid now all of a sudden to
appear to save face I have no idea but I
do not believe that that's the most
relevant part the most relevant part is
the DNC Democrats Inc have failed and
will continue to fail if they don't make
big changes and there's no indication
that they're ready to make them last
thought we've heard people dismiss this
entire story by saying hey come on the
election is over Hillary lost give it up
it's over or it's in the past is no more
valid here than it is with the fact that
if Trump Russia collusion took place
it's also in the past right that's
logically fallacious and you got to get
away from that that stuff will rot your
brain 100% so we're going to continue
following this the initial revelations
were certainly more shocking than what a
deeper look reveals but I don't think
that that's what the left needs to be
arguing about arguing about whether
Donna Brazile can be trusted 190 70 or
30% in terms of her allegations is not
going to fix the Democratic Party and
it's not clear that the Democratic Party
is going to be fixed at this time the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17
for a 40% discount off of your
membership